[Music]
on this friday night
alberta's alarming covet 19 situation
the mounting frustration and exhaustion
last week was probably
the toughest week that i've had of my
career an all-time high caseload
and low restrictions the potential deal
that could set
huawei's cfo free and the two michaels
new charges in the nova scotia massacre
the accusations against the gunman's
common-law wife and trying to profit
during the pandemic it's been a good way
to test some of the new digital
innovation
when an auth year forces small
businesses to go
online
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
lots to get to on this friday as we
track the spread of covet 19 in canada
and efforts to get it under control the
federal health minister
says canada could approve its first
vaccine in the next week
to 10 days but for now there is no
relief for regions with skyrocketing
case numbers
in places like alberta and manitoba
hospital beds are filling up fast and
health care workers are struggling to
keep up
i cannot emphasize enough the impact
that these kovid numbers are having
on our staff throughout the system they
are tired
they are fatigued they are stressed
by the changes and the intensity
that is upon them here's the national
picture
over the last week on average there have
been close to 2500 covet 19 patients
in canadian hospitals that includes
nearly 500 people in critical care
and on average in the last week 87
canadians died of covet 19
every day with case numbers climbing
fast
canada has hit another grim marker in
this pandemic
more than 400 000 canadians have now
tested positive for coven 19
and more than 12 400 canadians have died
every corner of the country has felt the
impact of the second wave
but in alberta it's a full-blown crisis
the province reported more than 1800 new
cases today for the second day in a row
as of tonight there are 530 covet 19
patients in hospital
99 of them in intensive care heather
york's west reports on the increasingly
desperate situation in hospitals
and the political decisions that led to
this crisis
inside alberta's hospitals exhaustion is
setting in
i can tell you that last week was
probably the toughest week that i've had
of my career
and yet there is little time to rest
record-breaking new case counts will
mean more covet patients
will soon need hospital care the health
minister spoke with her counterparts
last night
and assured them that the federal
government will offer all
support needed especially in alberta
where the numbers are rising alarmingly
the restrictions in alberta continue to
be some of the most
moderate in the country and have
remained so even as case numbers rise
ten days ago a ban took effect on
private indoor gatherings
business and school restrictions began
last friday
in the weeks since new infection numbers
have soared but the province's top
doctor says it's too soon to say if the
measures have failed
the bulk of these numbers that we're
seeing today would be from transmission
events that would have happened prior to
those restrictions
but during a facebook live event
thursday the premier said any new
measures would again
be targeted i suspect that if we do that
those restrictions will be
likely geographically focused alberta
may lead the country in active cases now
but last spring it was a different story
the province's response was the envy of
the country
but in may the premier's tone seemed to
change
the average age of death from covenant
alberta is 83
and i remind the house that the average
life expectancy in the province is age
82.
since then the premier has talked about
balancing the needs of alberta's economy
but as case numbers rise business owners
are growing frustrated too
i feel if he would have done this in
october if we would have had
when we knew the numbers were coming we
could see what was coming ahead
if we would have maybe done this earlier
we probably would have had our christmas
season what is
what is the best course of action you
know today can can change
depending on data depending on events
depending on things that you really have
no idea about
the former health minister knows what
it's like to govern through an emergency
he says decisions can be difficult but
leaders need to be able to change
course when required particularly when
lives are on the line
heather urex west global news calgary
we have an update tonight on an
escalating kova 19 outbreak on a remote
first nation
in northern manitoba chief eric redhead
of the shamatawa first nation
says 133 people have now tested positive
for the virus
and his community is struggling to get
the situation under control
he says a gymnasium set up to help
people self-isolate
is full and there are now daily flights
carrying sick people to winnipeg
redhead says he wants the military to be
sent in to help
that hasn't happened yet the federal
government says it's working to help the
community
using regional resources the federal
government still won't commit to a firm
date for when the first canadians will
get a covet-19 vaccine
but ottawa continues to prepare by
buying more vaccines and supplies
the goal is to increase delivery
capacity and fine-tune recommendations
for who will be first in line here's
david akin
for most canadians the first vaccines
cannot come
soon enough protecting you and your
family
and defeating covid19 is our top
priority
so ottawa is getting the country's house
in order for the biggest
mass immunization program in history
first order a business
buy enough vaccines so that everyone who
wants one
can get one on friday ottawa said it had
arranged
to get another 20 million doses from
vaccine maker moderna
this will bring canada's total allotment
of this vaccine to 40 million
doses to be delivered in 2021.
still decisions will have to be made as
to who gets one first
a federal task force issued revised
recommendations friday saying
first in line should be residents and
staff
of any retirement home long-term care
facility or chronic care hospital
then anyone over 70 starting with those
over 80 and then working backwards
towards the 70 year olds
then health care workers with a focus on
those on the front lines
next adults in indigenous communities
where the spread of the virus could have
disproportionate consequences
still it will be the provinces not
ottawa
that will have the final say on this
vaccine priority list
finally ottawa needs transportation help
to get these vaccines to provincial
and regional health care providers
specific logistics will be required to
keep the doses at very
very cold temperatures so ottawa signed
deals friday with
fedex express canada and inomar
strategies
to deliver the vaccines but there is
still much more to be done
before canada is ready to accept that
first
shipment of vaccines its work federal
officials say
they are confident of finishing by the
new year david aiken global news
ottawa job growth across canada slowed
last month
as the pandemic picked up steam
statistics canada says the economy added
62 000 jobs in november
compared with 84 000 in october the
gains were mostly focused in full-time
work with the addition of 99
000 jobs but those gains were offset by
a decline of 37
000 part-time positions canada is still
down 574 000 jobs from
before the pandemic november's
unemployment rate
stands at 8.5 percent many canadians are
unemployed right now because businesses
are struggling to stay open
but some store owners are coming up with
creative changes
to save the holiday shopping season mike
delay will have more on that
later on global national the economic
recovery in the u.s
is slowing as coven 19 cases surge south
of the border
employers added 245 000 jobs last month
far short of the 440 thousand economists
predicted
the unemployment rate edged down to 6.7
percent
the virus is breaking daily records in
the u.s for deaths hospitalizations and
new cases
close to 280 000 americans have died
from covet 19
as the country faces a rise in
infections from the thanksgiving holiday
u.s president donald trump still hasn't
conceded the election
but president-elect joe biden is now
laying out his strategy
to fight the pandemic jennifer johnson
reports
with hospitals and morgues running out
of space president-elect joe biden says
he will ask all americans to wear mass
starting january 20th the day he's
inaugurated
not forever 100 days and i think we'll
see a significant reduction
biden and former presidents obama bush
and clinton are promising to get
vaccinated publicly to encourage others
a new study shows confidence in the
safety of the vaccine is growing
sixty percent of americans now say they
will get the vaccine
please don't let yourself be biased just
open up your mind
look at the facts look at the data and
then make up your mind
vice president mike pence was briefed on
vaccine distribution at the centers for
disease control in georgia
within 48 hours from the fda's approval
we could be vaccinating people literally
in all 50 states
but already there are issues pfizer's
plan to ship 100 million doses by the
end of the year
has been cut to 50 million worldwide
after problems getting raw materials
hospital officials are also concerned
about distribution snags
the biggest challenge we have is we
don't know what we don't know
as americans anxiously await a
life-saving weapon
dr anthony fauci biden's new chief
medical advisor
warns this latest covet 19 post
thanksgiving surge
hasn't peaked yet the thing that
concerns me is that it butts right on
the christmas
holiday as people start to travel and
shop and congregate
california has just imposed its
strictest lockdown since the pandemic
began
colleges in maryland are graduating
their nursing students early
as hospitals face record numbers of
patients
things were steady and then all of a
sudden boom
and it just seems to be non-stop
millions have their eyes on congress
as it continues to work on a 900 billion
coronavirus economic aid package
president trump says he will sign the
bill once it passes
extending unemployment benefits to
millions and greater protection from
evictions
jennifer johnson global news washington
the global tally of kova 19 cases has
hit a staggering new record
infections have now topped the 65
million mark and more than 1.5 million
people have lost their lives in the last
week alone
over ten thousand people died every day
from the virus
worldwide in italy tight new
restrictions are now in effect for the
holidays
they include a strong recommendation
against hosting guests ski resorts are
also staying closed over christmas
there's a ban on travel between regions
starting december 21st
and there will be no midnight mass italy
is seeing a downward trend in infection
rates but is struggling with a high
death toll 814 people died from kova 19
in the last 24 hours the u.s department
of justice is refusing to comment on
reports a plea deal could be in the
works for mong wang zhou
the huawei executive was arrested in
vancouver in 2018
at the request of the united states
she's accused of violating american
sanctions against iran
the possibility of a legal arrangement
raises hopes
two canadians held in china in apparent
retaliation
could be released but as abigail beeman
reports
hmong has to carefully weigh her options
the deferred prosecution agreement
reportedly being discussed between
mangwon joe's lawyers and the u.s
department of justice could see her
return home to china
but she'd have to admit to wrongdoing
according to the wall street journal and
reuters she isn't prepared to do that
she should not admit to any wrongdoing
if there was no wrongdoing
she followed the rules if she admits the
wrongdoing just to get out of canada
her future journeys to various countries
in the world will be denied
mung's lawyers told global news they
wouldn't comment the prime minister
wouldn't talk about a possible deal
either
but justin trudeau did weigh in on the
reasons this case carries so much weight
for canada
michael kovrig and michael spavor for
almost two years we've been working
extremely hard to bring home these two
michaels
it is an absolute priority for the
government um i won't be commenting on
any of the recent reports
beijing accused canada of playing a role
that is not honorable calling it purely
and essentially a serious political
incident
and on politics there is a question of
how much this has to do with president
donald trump's
looming end of term the most likely
explanation is that the trump
administration
is concerned that joe biden
would decide to unconditionally withdraw
the extradition request
charles burton says that route would be
better for canada
if the deferred prosecution goes through
then canada still has to negotiate with
china for the release of those two
michaels
and that would probably mean that we'd
have to make some sort of concessions
to the chinese government that we
normally would not like to do
burton is leading the canadian arm of a
new global initiative
hashtag free china hostages calling on
people to mail
christmas cards for koverick and spavor
to the chinese ambassador in their
country
burton doesn't expect the letters to
reach their intended recipients behind
bars
rather it's about sending a message to
the chinese government
abigail beeman global news ottawa
an uproar over the prime minister's
remarks coming up why
india is angry
three people are now facing charges in
connection with april's mass shooting in
nova scotia
rcmp say the gunman's common law spouse
52
lisa banfield is among three people
charged with unlawfully transferring
ammunition
police say those charged had no prior
knowledge of the gunman's actions
22 people were killed in several rural
nova scotia communities
canada's high commissioner to india was
scolded today over prime minister justin
trudeau's remarks in support of indian
farmers
in a statement india's ministry of
external affairs says
comments by trudeau constitute an
unacceptable interference in internal
affairs
it goes on to say such actions if
continued would have a seriously
damaging
impact on ties between india and canada
today when asked about his remarks
trudeau doubled down
canada will always stand up for the
right of peaceful peaceful protest
anywhere around the world and we're
pleased to see
moves towards de-escalation and dialogue
on monday during an online event trudeau
said he was concerned about the protests
in
india and that canada would always
support the rights of farmers to be
heard
tens of thousands of indian farmers are
demonstrating against new laws they say
will subject them to corporate
exploitation
by driving down product prices
still ahead getting a potential vaccine
here from switzerland
and the canadian helping to make it
happen
moderna is one of the leading vaccine
candidates waiting for health canada
approval
in anticipation its two manufacturing
plants one in the u.s
the other in europe are operating around
the clock trying to meet global demand
as carolyn jarvis reports the entire
supply chain is getting ready
starting with a canadian at the top
in a quiet swiss valley a canadian is
leading the charge to get vaccines
back home what's the question you get
asked most frequently
when is it going to arrive when can we
see it nicolas charney
is the head of international
manufacturing and distribution
for medera maker of one of the leading
coveted 19 vaccine candidates
moderna teamed up with manufacturing
firm lonza
based here in switzerland to create a
second production hub
outside the u.s what does your family
back in sherbrooke say
hey they're all behind us they're
telling me hey how fast can we get this
because we want to see you we want you
to travel and come and see us again
construction on moderna's four
production lines is still ongoing
but it's expected this site will produce
upwards of 300 million doses by the end
of 2021
and when combined with its manufacturing
plant in the us
modernist says it could make as many as
a billion doses next year
if it's approved by health canada
canadians will start seeing that supply
in early 2021 canada is one of the
countries that move
very very fast in securing vaccines with
us
it's one of the first countries or one
of the
top countries to to receive our supply
also
from switzerland modernist vaccine will
be sent to spain
to the company rovi that will put it
into vials
it will then be shipped to a central
depot in canada managed by the federal
government
and distributed to the provinces it will
then coordinate the onward flow of
vaccines
to those points of administration
based on their internal plans and
resources
unlike pfizer's vaccine which requires
ultracold storage at minus 70 celsius
modernist needs a conventional lab
freezer at -20
these are all going by truck out to
whether it's out to vancouver
or if it's out east to newfoundland it's
all by track
but until the vaccine is approved all
eyes are here
on the town beneath the alps where the
vaccine
is being made on your end it's coming
yes yes it's coming carolyn jarvis
global news
toronto and carolyn sits down with the
head of toronto's immunization task
force for an exclusive interview
on how canada's largest city is
preparing for the vaccine's arrival and
deployment
you can see that on the new reality with
donna friesen on saturday
right here on global seasonal shopping
solutions up next how small businesses
hope to beat
big competition
holiday shopping could be a lifeline for
some canadian businesses
with so many closed by pandemic
restrictions shopping has moved
online that shift is hurting local
retailers
while giants like amazon shatter records
as mike delay explains
that's inspired some creative solutions
from small retailers
to beat the competition this christmas
there are few events in toronto that
compare to the distillery district's
christmas market
three-quarters of a million visitors
turned the stalls and stores
into a giant festive zoo the contrast to
2020 is what you'd expect it to be
with less foot traffic and then a
lockdown melissa austria of gots style
menswear had no choice but to get
creative
so she now has a more robust website and
is offering virtual shopping through
instagram and facebook
nothing is off the table it's been a
good way to
test some of the new digital innovation
that we were planning on doing and now
we're just trying everything at once
but not all businesses particularly
those geared towards the holidays have
the option to adapt
the annual sleigh ride in armstrong bc
was canceled this year
organizers just couldn't see running it
with restrictions
and retail needs those horses
a recent survey found that 30 percent of
businesses are seeing normal sales and
60 percent are fully open
and that has led to some unfestive phone
calls at the canadian federation of
independent business
can't really give you the reaction
without swearing the toronto bar miracle
sells christmas or at least it did
opening day is when the current lockdown
was announced
so all they can do is sell cocktail kits
online
and cross their candy canes they'll be
able to open closer to christmas
the quote at my home bar civil liberties
for the last
i guess nine months now has been high
seas make strong sailors
and i feel like we're going to have a
really strong vibrant industry on the
other side of this
it's that other side that led to the
creation of bag of toronto
a project created by nick milam and
derrick liu to help small business
neither works in retail nor do they
profit from the proceeds of the curated
bags
filled with local products helping
people that we don't even know are
business owners that we don't even know
is
truly satisfying i think the only profit
they hope to see
is a happy and healthy holiday shopping
season
microlight global news toronto and that
is global national for this friday night
i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is from inside the
anne of green gables museum in
kensington prince edward island we'd
love to see your corner of this country
so please send us your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com thank you
for watching and i'll see you back here
tomorrow
have a great night
you